THEY ARE AMBITIOUS TO DO A LOT
MORE.
>> Neil: WE ARE MONITORING THE
PRESIDENT.
INTERRUPTING THIS BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY RIGHT NOW.
YOU MIGHT HAVE SEEN THAT THIS
BIG EVENT.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT INDICATED WAS
HIS GOAL WAS TO HAVE IT BY THE
END OF THE YEAR.
VERY AGGRESSIVE.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS BEING VERY
AGGRESSIVE ON REPORTS THAT CHINA
IS TRYING TO HACK INTO THESE
RESEARCH EFFORTS AND STEAL THIS.
THE ACTING SECRETARY WITH US
NOW.
TODD WOLF.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME.
I KNOW YOU ARE LOOKING AT
GETTING ON TOP OF THIS.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT WHAT
CHINESE HACKERS MIGHT BE DOING
TO TRY TO STEAL THIS?
>> WELL, THANKS, NEIL, FOR
HAVING ME ON.
WHATEVER CYBERSECURITY HAS DONE
THIS WEEK IS TO PUT ON AN
ADVISORY, MAKING SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS, WHEN IT COMES TO
COVID-19 RESEARCH UNDERSTAND
THAT WE HAVE SOME BAD ACTORS.
CHINA SPECIFICALLY.
SOME NONTRADITIONAL ACTORS THAT
ARE TARGETING OUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY WHEN IT COMES TO THEIR
RESEARCH.
TARGETING INDIVIDUALS SUCH AS
OUR OWN RESEARCHERS.
SO WE WANTED TO MAINTAIN SOME
AWARENESS ON THIS SO THAT OUR
U.S. COMMUNITY-BASED RESEARCHERS
COULD UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING
ON.
OUR HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY COULD
UNDERSTAND WAS GOING ON.
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DID BACK
A COUPLE MONTHS AGO, AGAIN WITH
DHS.
WE PUT OUT AN ALERT WITH THEIR
U.K. COUNTERPARTS WHERE WE SET
WE MAY HAVE MALICIOUS CYBER
ACTORS AGAIN TARGETING
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS.
I THINK WHAT WE HAVE SEEN, NEIL,
IS THAT WE SEE MORE TARGETING
OTHER HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY.
SPECIFICALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
CHINA.
THIS ISN’T A SURPRISE.
WE KNOW THAT CHINA FOR A VERY
LONG TIME HAS BEEN VERY BAD
ACTORS IN CYBERSPACE, SO THIS IS
A NEWS TO US, BUT WE NEED TO
STAY ON IT.
WE NEED TO STAY ENGAGED WITH OUR
OTHER PARTNERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR PRIVATE SECTOR PARTNERS IN
THE HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY AND
OTHERS ARE AWARE OF THIS AND
HAVE THEIR SHIELDS UP AS WELL.
>> Neil: SO I TAKE IT WHAT YOU
ARE SAYING IS TO ADVANCE THEIR
OWN POSSIBLE REMEDY, VACCINES.
ANYTHING THAT MIGHT DEAL WITH
THIS AND FIND A CURE FOR THIS.
>> YES.
THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
I THINK WHAT THEY ARE TARGETING
AGAIN IS NOT ONLY THE
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY THAT WE
ARE CREATING HERE.
AGAIN, WE TALK ABOUT COVID-19
RESEARCH, BUT AGAIN, TARGETING
OUR PERSONNEL TO STEAL THAT
INFORMATION SO THAT THEY CAN BE
AT THE CUTTING EDGE OF THEIR
RESEARCH, AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT’S PROTECTIVE, AND
THAT’S PART OF WHAT WE DO FROM A
CYBER PERSPECTIVE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
AGAIN, WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS
AT THE FBI TO PROSECUTE WHEN
APPROPRIATE.
>> Neil: NOW, AND THE
ADMINISTRATION, YOU HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN RESTRICTING
IMMIGRATION.
HAS THIS ELEVATED TO THE POINT
OF TARGETING CHINESE STUDENTS
WHO WANT TO STUDY HERE, BE HERE?
EVEN ON TWO-YEAR PLANS WHERE
THEY ARE LEARNING JUST BEYOND
COLLEGE MATERIAL AND STUFF, IT
SEEMS TO GO A LITTLE WIDER?
>> IT DOES, AND AGAIN, FROM A
DEPARTMENT PERSPECTIVE, THERE
ARE A NUMBER OF VISAS THAT
CHINESE STUDENTS AND RESEARCHERS
AND OTHERS UTILIZE.
TAKING A LOOK AT HOW WE ADDRESS
THE FRAUD THAT WE ALL NOW IS IN
THAT SYSTEM.
AND I THINK IT TAKES ON SPECIAL
IMPORTANCE HERE AS WE COME OUT
OF THIS PANDEMIC.
AS WE LOOK TO RESTART THE
ECONOMY, MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE JOBS AVAILABLE TO
AMERICANS, TO INTEGRATE THEM
BACK INTO THE WORKFORCE, SO WE
ARE HAPPY TO BRING THE BEST ON
THE BRIGHTEST INTO THE U.S., BUT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
RESERVE THOSE JOBS AT LEAST
INITIALLY SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
U.S. WORKERS REGAIN THEIR
LIVELIHOOD AND PARTICIPATE, SO
THERE ARE SOME STUDENT VISAS
THAT WE ARE TAKING A LOOK AT.
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS FRAUD AND
ABUSE IN THE PROGRAM, AND IT IS
TIME THAT WE LOOK AT THAT.
>> Neil: WHAT ABOUT CHINESE
STUDENTS WHO JUST COME TO STUDY
HERE?
ARE YOU CRACKING DOWN ON THAT?
THOSE THAT ARE ALREADY HERE TO
STUDY?
CLASSES ARE VIRTUAL EVERYWHERE.
BUT DO YOU WANT TO TAMP THIS
DOWN, COME THE FALL?
>> WELL, WE ARE CERTAINLY TAKING
A LOOK AT THAT, AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS HERE AND
OVERSEAS LOOKING TO COME IN AS
WELL.
AND I THINK AGAIN FROM DHS
PERSPECTIVE, MAKING SURE THAT WE
CAN ENSURE THAT THEY ARE COMING
HERE TO THE U.S. FOR THE RIGHT
REASONS, THEY ARE HERE TO STUDY.
THEY ARE NOT HERE TO DO OTHER
NEFARIOUS THINGS.
SO WE ARE DOING THAT AGAIN IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OTHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES INSIDE
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT, AND I THINK
THAT’S IMPORTANT.
I WILL ALSO SAY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT TOOK SOME ACTION
EARLIER THIS WEEK LOOKING AT
CHINESE JOURNALIST THAT ARE
AGAIN COMING HERE UNDER A
CERTAIN VISA.
THROUGHOUT THE DURATION OF THEIR
STAY, SO IN MANY CASES, THAT WAS
YEARS AND YEARS AND YEARS,
UTILIZING THE VISA FOR OTHER
PURPOSES.
PERHAPS DOING OTHER THINGS THAT
WERE NOT CORRECT.
SO WHAT WE DID IS WE TAMP DOWN
ON THAT AND SAID YOU CAN STAY
HERE FOR 90 DAYS AT A TIME.
YOU CAN COME BACK, GET THAT
REASSESS, BUT YOU WILL HAVE TO
DO AN INTERVIEW WITH DHS, AND WE
ARE GOING TO ASK SOME HARD
QUESTIONS, SO THIS IS AN OVERALL
EFFORT TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
LOOKING CLOSELY AT THESE
INDIVIDUALS, NOT GIVING THEM
BLANKET VISAS FOR YEARS AT A
TIME.
AGAIN, THAT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE PROTECT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.